what's going on guys this is rob and as
you can see i have a new set up for all
my stuff for my video blogs and my
marble explains stuff i've got a much
bigger desk and i had before which is
really exciting and of course I've got
pictures that I need to put up and I'm
going to put a TV I'll be right there on
that wall back there although i'm not
entirely sure that's what i wanted to do
but um either way you know I'm really
glad with the whole new setup that I
have here but for those of you guys who
follow both Benny and myself you guys
know that we went live today with our
very first live I guess live stream of
the weekly pool podcast and it went
amazing it was really nice it was me
Benny and Sal Dave actually had to work
today so he wasn't able to make it in
but it was a it was a great podcast we
really really enjoyed it and we really
kind of asked the question do you guys
want to see us live stream it again so
if you guys haven't seen it yet head
over to binny's channel and you can
check out the podcast there how we're
going to do in the future not entirely
sure what may upload it to my channel we
may live stream on both Vinny's channel
and my channel and 107 sure which
direction that's going to go yet but
this was just kind of a tentative thing
this was just really kind of 22 to try
it and see if it works and it worked
really well in the other the chat was
very very interactive and people were
asking all kinds of questions you know
and it was it was really fun it was a
really great experience and it's
definitely something that we want to
keep doing we really want to keep live
streaming so again it's it's it's fun
it's amazing how far stuff is progressed
you know I never would have thought that
when i first hit up many that we would
end up where we are now you know where
we're like doing podcasts and we're
combining our efforts on video video
creation and all kinds of cool stuff and
with Sal on board it's just it makes for
a really fun thing so again if you guys
are not familiar with sales channel it's
a TV little house and i'll have a link
down in the description you guys can go
check it out but it's fun why this is
all just uh this is all just really
really fun it's really exciting as you
guys know i have the video up the final
tie-in for civil war issue number for
this is part 5 and it's the final the
final video for those tie-ins so on
monday will have civil war issue number
five and then we'll do the tie-ins again
thankfully will have fewer tie-ins I
think between civil war issue number
five and six do we will with four or
five so we won't have like you know four
or five different videos I think we'll
be able to do in about three videos or
so also we're just about at the end of
Civil War so let me know what you guys
want to see after Civil War let me know
what you guys want me to do if you guys
want me to do like Jean Grey if you guys
want me to do Silver Surfer or any other
character that I haven't done yet my
idea I want to do Silver Surfer after
your civil wars over but it may be that
this is a comic that I do or character
that I do some time later on down the
low later on down the line let me know
you guys want to see because I know that
you guys have a lot of requests and
we're going to be back we're going to
take a break from doing crossover events
for a while just because it's mentally
exhausting doing these major crossover
events and so it'll be a little while
before we do you know house of them or
anything like that I think videos going
to wait till the end of September's that
will give us a nice month or so to
really kind of do a whole bunch of video
so of course will do Marvel request
monday that'll come back we'll do
thursday videos and we'll keep doing
that monday and thursdays and it's a
chance to you guys to get the videos
that you've been wanting to see so let
me know what characters you want to see
let me know if you want to see you know
somebody kind of crazy Lou know if you
want to see somebody obscure we can do
the purple man you know we talked about
obscure characters during the podcast I
had mentioned how purple man was a super
obscure character in Marvel Comics and
so you know let me know what you guys
are interested in seeing and and I will
I will do my best to get you that
because as you guys know I'm here to
bring you what you want to see so so let
me know and and yeah so that's pretty
much it really went a whole lots of the
video blog today but it's kind of want
to talk to you guys for a second but you
guys know what's going on and yeah so
I'll catch you guys later peace
Oh